what is the Pearson correlation with the
help of Pearson correlation we can
measure the linear relationship between
two variables for example is there a
relationship between a person's salary
and age here we can determine how strong
the correlation is and in which
direction the correlation goes we can
read both in the Pearson correlation
coefficient R which is between -1 and 1.
a positive correlation exists when large
values of one variable go along with
large values of the other variable or
when small values of one variable go
along with small values of the other
variable a positive correlation is found
for example for body size and shoe size
the result is a positive correlation
coefficient a negative correlation
exists when large values of one variable
go along with small values of the other
variable and vice versa a negative
correlation usually exists between
product price and sales volume the
result is a negative correlation
coefficient